you have no idea how glad I am America
got Biden I can't even describe it to
you I love the fact that Biden's our
president because of one reason you know
why because everyone's seeing what the
opposite policies look like and people
behind closers are like oh my God this
isn't and I voted for this guy do you
know how many people have voters remorse
right now a lot of people I know a lot
of people that are voters remorse you
know what's the only reason people who
have voters remorse won't say publicly
because we hate being wrong our egos in
a way there's no way we're going to
admit to Isle of Voters remorse voters
anymore they'll still go by anything
about that guy no people have voters
remorse tell me what's going on with
your job today tell me what's going on
with the economy today tell me what's
going on with your lifestyle today tell
me what's going on with your gas station
today tell me what's going on tell me
what you're thinking about I'm so glad
this happened for people to realize what
the opposite looks like the next time
around think twice when you vote